this season of sex ed is brought to you
by Lilo stick around until after the
episode to learn a little bit more
how was she in bed
Sade was excellent in bed he's really
good in bed he made me finish like a
bunch before finishing himself yeah he's
great
he's like really good in bed
[Applause]
[Music]
was sex talked about your home growing
up I actually was very much like
abstinental marriage kind of person I
think when like puberty started to hit
you start like feeling things and body
change and all that occurs I had sex for
the first time at like 16 I cried
afterwards had a lot of guilt really fun
great experience poor guy
um I knew that there were like sexual
things that happened in life but it
wasn't something that I thought was like
applicable to me kind of until puberty
I met Garrett my freshman year at Yale I
had come to college very much trying to
be single I actually remember the
circumstances of this very well because
it was the first or second day of
October break freshman year of college
yeah it was like a really small school
so like I've interacted with him kind of
on and off since I kind of like know who
he dated and stuff like that but I don't
I didn't know him very well personally
and then moved to LA in June of 2020 and
he matched with Mana dating app until we
went on a date again I did just ghost
him I wouldn't do that if I could go
back and fix things tell me the story of
your first hookup
um so we were in someone's dorm room we
were playing that game never have I ever
I remember specifically because during
the game of never have I ever I uh I
shared that I had never had a [__] to
completion people started to head out
one by one over the course of the night
and then as luck would have it should I
were the last ones sticking around one
thing led to another I don't remember
much about it I remember him being very
nice and very kind but outside of that I
feel like I was kind of really very much
like exploring sexual bounds in my life
and it wasn't anything that was like
particularly memorable though a lot of
that first kind of semester hookups bled
together for me
what's one thing she could improve upon
in bed
um we were like both 18 at the time so I
think the you know the ceiling of how
good it can be is is only so high at 18
I'm sure there were plenty of critiques
on my end and not even know what I was
looking for when I have hookups now I
talk a lot more about like what we like
and I'm much more like comfortable in
bed and I feel like when I was hooking
up with people in that like freshman
year headspace where a lot of my sexual
encounters were kind of validation
driven I don't think I would have spoken
up if like something didn't go well or
like if I didn't finish and now I'm much
more open about that stuff so if
anything like was poor it probably was
like situational and not like him as a
person
describe your relationship with her as
it stands now
um casual friends yeah acquaintances uh
yeah I moved to LA like less than a year
ago but we like matched on Bumble when I
got here and like hung out and then we
kind of lost touch and then she hit me
up and was like hey do you want to be in
this video and I was like yeah why not
asking hookups around La like would you
want to come shoot a video about us
hooking up and he was like yeah sure
which I think said something really
really nice about him I think he's
really wonderful and like opened and
kind and like is someone I would want to
pursue as a friend I just don't see us
ever going somewhere like romantically
foreign
via dating apps we met in a park near
where I live Luke and I matched on a
couple dating apps and then we went on a
date in a park and we had a fun time
chatting and we're connecting on a lot
of levels and then we decided to hook up
that night and we've kind of like hooked
up casually since
did you use protection
yes we definitely used condoms on the
first round yes on the second round no I
feel really bad about it that's
definitely not smart like I don't
recommend that but I again like have the
birth control implant so I feel
sometimes a little bit better about that
but no oops
how is she in bed
shade was excellent in bed he's really
good in bed so our first round lasted
for a really long time I remember that
he made me finish like a bunch before
finishing himself yeah he's great he's
like really good in bed it was built on
a lot of communication there's this I
think misconception that people have
wordless passionate amazing sex that I
think comes from movies and that's just
really not the case he's really good at
focusing on his partner in bed and
that's something I think I don't always
find very adventurous very kind first
person to ever make me squirt which was
really cool and like he's like pretty
committed to doing that every time
what happened next we both were very
okay with keeping things pretty casual I
don't know I'm like a big believer in
like casual sex can be casual sex and
like not every relationship needs to be
romantic sometimes I think about it like
when he comes over and we you know sit
and talk for a long time and like like
maybe this is like the relationship that
I want to have and then I think we also
offered each other
some pretty important emotional support
that was unexpected
um I was sexually assaulted a couple
months ago
and like Luke was just really there for
me and like he's the first person I
slept with after the assault and in the
middle of a hookup like broke down and
like he immediately caught it he was
like very careful to like ask if I was
okay like even if it ended horribly
tomorrow like I could never regret
hooking up with someone who has just
been such a wonderful support system and
such a hard time in my life all I'd
hoped for is that we remain on good
terms and that that we look back on
whatever we've had fondly
so we met back in 2018 interning at
Goldman Sachs together
Jess and I met in our 2018 Goldman Sachs
summer internship she worked in finance
and I worked in HR and we sat in each
other on the first day and I remember
looking at her and being like Oh my gosh
that is such a hot suit she's beautiful
and she's wearing this black suit and I
remember thinking I want to be her
friend
Jess and I have just like made out again
like we met in 2018 and then this
weekend is the first time we've seen
each other in person since then so like
it's cool to have those conversations
it's definitely more like emotional less
physical how good is she as a kisser
great incredible
she's really hot it was good she said it
was a good kisser so that was good
she's good solid 10 out of 10. I know
she's like wary about coming across as
like a [__] boy but like I think she's
really really awesome and I also like
know about her other dating life and I
know that
she's good and bad from what I've heard
do you ever think about them fantasize
about them
I wouldn't say I fantasize about her or
think about her in that way just because
we do have like this incredible
friendship and we've talked about dating
and we've talked about going into a
relationship together and I don't think
I would want to jeopardize our
friendship anytime soon just for the
chance of dating even if we don't kind
of go that route she's definitely like a
platonic life partner someone I want in
my life like we've talked about like
buying a house together or like we have
that like if she turns 40 you're both
single we're getting married type thing
but it's definitely like a different
relationship than
a lot of the other ones I've had in the
past
[Music]
I mean maybe kiss but I don't think we
would hook up because that's a pretty
hard boundary for me
I think it's a relationship that I'm
really really really scared to ruin
Jess is one of the best people I've ever
met so I think that like question is
always going to be there
I would be down to I just don't want to
ever
do something that would like ruin the
relationship that we've built and like I
think it's hard to hook up with somebody
and then have them go back to long
distance and like not talk again so I
don't know
um I think in the past I really
struggled with having that line between
friends and hookups and partners and I
think especially with our friendship I
don't want it to go anywhere anytime
soon so I want to work hard to make sure
that doesn't happen or jeopardize that
in any way
I think she'd rate me pretty well in bed
maybe not maybe not well I guess I was
18 at the time God knows what I was
doing in there I was
worse
sorry Garrett has to be Garrett just
because like I don't remember it very
much he might have been incredible also
it was years ago he's had time to
improve
right so like
I assume there's been an upward
trajectory
I don't have any regrets about my sexual
experiences in life I think that's
something I'm I'm grateful to have
explored and I'm grateful that I gave
myself the grace and the time to like
explore that even if it wasn't the
healthiest thing ever I've grown a lot
as like a sexual person I'm really vocal
now and like I asked for what I want and
I discuss sexual situations in advance
I'm also pretty like adventurous and
open and I really like a lot of those
things about myself which I think makes
me a fun partner to have in bed if
that's something you're into
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's talk about first impression what
are you noticing here I feel like this
is a sex toy
this yeah my friend gifted me I mean I
have it this is nice good color really
just great color assortment if you're
gonna go to battle with one of these
devices I would hold this one yeah you
can hurt someone with that can we get
some of these
all right you want to learn about a
couple of these do you want to read some
cute cards yeah yeah okay I was like I'm
a little scared now
this is the Soraya wave from Lilo it's
fully waterproof and rechargeable so
it's easy to keep clean and easy to
explore pleasure in the bath or shower
the toe curling wave motion technology
is inspired by the caress of a Lover's
finger for a tidal wave climax that
crashes over you again and again and
again goodness me I'll be honest I'm the
number one person that's completely
ignorant to All Things sex so I'm
definitely like looking at this and
being like I didn't know if we had that
many different parts of our bodies I
haven't dabbled in a long time so uh
it's good to get reacquainted with these
that's it that's it oh that's easier
than I thought oh fine thank you guys I
love that we're doing this you guys it's
fun not a terrible first day
oh awesome
survived we hope you enjoy yourselves
courtesy of Lilo and Jubilee